what did your friends and family think
about when you basically became a
YouTuber were they concerned about you
what were people in your world or were
they like what are you doing Stephen My
First Youtube upload was 10 years ago
this month wow so 2013 and a couple
people told me about getting on YouTube
and I was just like man I've had like TV
shows with my name in the title like
I've had like number one movies now I'm
gonna upload the YouTube video it felt
like so depressing I didn't think that
there was even like money in it dude it
brought about a complete rebirth for me
and my career like now I identify as a
YouTuber well the thing is YouTube's
bigger than television now I mean Mr
Beast destroys the ratings on probably
any television show besides the Super
Bowl or something I think even bites the
Super Bowl there you go yeah